les municipales la peau seront
déterminantes pour l'avenir de françois
bayrou candidat face au maire sortant
ce dernier ancien fabusien a reçu depuis
l'appui de l'ump
quant à la candidate socialiste elle est
aussi en situation de créer la surprise
alors quels sont les ingrédients de
cette sauce béarnaise hélène ig et
frédéric basket s'occuper de peau c'est
tous les jours c'est pas maintenant
devant des caméras devant des
journalistes nous des électeurs dur en
affaires
pas toujours convaincu de l'utilité
d'une figure nationale dans leur ville
pacy couleur locale à leur goût même
s'il est un homme du cru
françois bayrou se sent avant tout
l'homme a beau être tout ce que vous
savez la gauche la droite le président
de la république que tout le monde s'est
engagé pour essayer d'empêcher cette
élection il faut dire que le président
de la république est venu en personne à
pau le mois dernier républicain françois
bayrou l'avait accueilli à l'aéroport
mais c'est le maire socialiste sortant
yves urieta que nicolas sarkozy est venu
soutenir aussitôt exclu du ps
yves urieta former une liste avec l'ump
l'ouverture à la berner
l'ump soutient et le présent ne rêvait
que soutient la démarche originale je
mène sur fond de rassembler des femmes
et des hommes au delà des partis du coup
la candidate socialiste se sent pousser
des ailes
elle revendique une liste cohérente il
ya des listes ou via des ex ump ou des
ex psd les déçus de ceux ci dessus de
cela l ain ont tous des gens de gauche
elle insiste aussi sur sa bonne
implantation locale dont les palois ont
besoin c'est d'un maire ou d'une mère
qui soit ici françois bayrou 7 le risque
qu'il prend une victoire à pau lui
permettrait de conforter ses positions
un échec l'isolerait encore un peu plus